je perds la huitième guen je perds un
neuvième gain je paierai 10e km
je perds la 11e 15e place les amis
aujourd'hui et à caution puisque cela
fait maintenant deux semaines que je
n'ai pas joué en classe et sur overblog
chutant à la frustration était mais je
me suis entraîné dur en partie rapide
pour qu'aujourd'hui devant vos yeux
ébahis
je pense vraiment ou alors j'ai pris mon
téléphone comme ça j'ai appelé michael
farkas qui ont fait les oiseaux barocci
j'aurais dit les gars y'a moyen on
s'arrange bonjour alpha bonjour mitia
comment allez-vous bonjour bonjour vous
même vous savez j'aurais pu passer
diamant seul sans aucun problème c'est
juste que voilà je voulais que mes potes
bénéficier un peu de mon skill je
voulais vous faire passer des armes
encore ces gens que moi je voulais que
tu me connais un peu donc voilà donc ces
voix là ah oui les amis nous n'avons pas
joué avant de lancer l'enregistrement de
cette vidéo je suis à 2955 de compte il
faut qu'on gagne
deuxième pour que je fasse diamant ouais
ça fait déjà une minute qu'on attendait
ok la garder sur gibraltar nous devons
gagner vous m'entendez oui ok les gars
c'est parti c'est parti c'est parti
c'est parti les toros du diamant au yen
mais on peut dire que les gars base ils
montent à l'étagé monte à l'étagé heures
contre x et façon les gars salut les
gars c'est le patron à nax ray olalalala
comme ça joue bien mais comme sa poche
on n'avait pas vu ça depuis des mois on
sait la police a joué extrêmement bien
c'est d'une beauté incandescente ça ne
veut rien dire attention enfin la fin la
part à la vie et la mort il est mort le
reinhardt von arx reinhardt
oh là là mais euler pool de tulle ok les
gars gauche 7 de taux d'accès des gages
à l'égard jeu menu il est très très bon
salaire très très bon je l'aimé
énormément l ayant atteint de sécurité
captée par les débats attends moi
attendez moi j'attends maintenant à toi
tu vois ses mécanos week-end
c'est ça do with my band ou bi kalou
mais ce sont bien eux aussi se sont
guère surtout d'agir mais je suis
content on a fait le premier mon bon
combo de ma chaîne youtube parce qu'en
45 ans y avait jamais eu ça à temps les
gars j'ai un coup de téléphone attendent
trop mal joué et à l'eau oui bien sûr on
le comprend avantage dans fait pas ouais
bon c'était le csa et menaçaient de
mettre la vidéo - de 18 sur les chaises
passage bat lucas ça commence bien mais
pas fini c'est normal d'aller aussi vite
sur cette map ou pas en tout cas non
banon bombe à alarobia à la font recours
pour que les glaces pour qui le recul
est aussi en débat au dessus on dit pas
mais j'ai peur ou est tu mets kahlo
viens avec moi mon chéri autant il me
suis salarié n'a en rien non mais oui
comment ce style à wels à il faut se
ressaisir les gars il faut social ils
ont mis eux aussi peu de temps que nous
les gars j'ai un jeu je joue tellement à
ce jeu en vidéo que j'ai pas l'habitude
de parler en fait quand je joue je leur
en platine expliqué en retard mais c'est
pas mal ça retard de huit adultes et
prévoir
oh
c'est ça qu'on veut
comment je suis en train de trahir mon
gas jamais autant la garde protégeant
c'est comme si j'ai envie de prouver aux
gens que je méritais d'être diamant non
mais je me rendais diamant ça ce n'est
pas tout hsbc qui me fait des petits
l'ags a et 2 minutes 20 à terre les gars
finalement c'est quoi
mais non mais c'est vrai tu verras
nature et non à celui des solutions
merci ça me fait très plaisir tu penses
que je peux faire un bon ok les gars ça
règle sa rive des gens sur le point avec
des gens sur le point c'est bien jusqu'à
la résistance c 17 189 morts fin en
poche les couilles je vais mourir
ils ont tout lâché les gars c'est pas
grave non correctes 39 secondes regarde
regarde le temps qu'il nous reste par
rapport à eux les gars ok les gars je
suis attendu j'aurais jamais dû mais je
m'en bats les couilles
ok les gars je dois chargé pour un bac s
qui est finalement très très humiliant
les nuages vont embarquer quelqu'un je
vais amener quelqu'un au poste attention
monsieur vie au poste
voilà c'est bon il en reste dix secondes
et garçons finissent en seconde ça ne
l'empêché de venir pêcher de dire si je
vais les empêcher je suis devant
finalement je suis devant le chien
je
ok les gars j'ai baisé la hanche et
derrière je suis d'ailleurs aux jeunes
des coups partout auquel m j'ai dit
jeudi à la pana mercredi
excusez moi c'est mes racines de
policiers à la quille c'est pas fini
mais complice attendait jouer avec des
rondes sommes là les mecs qui prennent
chez sont morts ok les gars c'est parti
vous êtes des flandres tous derrière moi
et bah non parce que vous avez joué sur
le nombre de buts et à chaque âge sur la
gauche sur un voyage à cannes ok les
gars vous assurez j'avoue c'est très
bien je veux que ça se passe très bien
là haut en couleurs ces personnes quoi
vous dire ok les gars je crois que c'est
la victoire
on leur a pissé littéralement dessus
marché assez comme celles qui militent
et bien c'est quoi j'allais dire aux
gens de suivre sur twitter et dans je ne
dis pas oui à ses mécanos mais c'est
loin beaucoup beau nom youtube à
divertir le montage peut pas monter les
gars je veux pas monter lalalalalala on
a fait un bon combat quand même et on en
est à combien de côtes
oasis n'est pas loin tu dois être à 80
très violent ben brik à mika tu as gagné
tu as gagné ce magnifique cascade romane
parce que je subis la 80 ans c'est bon
j'ai cherché à bois et bloquaient aussi
[Musique]
ok les gars temples de nubie moi les
gars je reprends mon camionneurs je
reprends mon agent de police ont fait
remarquer des voyous let's go oui ok il
a voulu marquer mais c'est moi la police
au total 3
c'est l'agent de police je peux pas j'ai
la fierté c'est bon c'est bon je
m'embarque quelqu'un les premiers essais
le groupe sp 10 mai au caire mme bazzo
bazzo baisse allez c'est drôle ça dégage
web avant on est en zone partie un
soldeur dedans je me tentait une
fraîcheur je perde jamais réussir c'est
pas grave monsieur vous êtes embarqué
par la police
hockey acih mettra ça dégage on est de
grands coups de marteau à l'ego bon
concept artist parti
vous voulez mais tous nous ok les gars
aient pris venez venez en face à gauche
on passe à gauche on passe à gauche on
passe à l'ouest on s'arrête à fait des
deux commentateurs sportifs sont braqués
nombre à son bras ce qu'ils avancent
attaque à ce qu'ils annoncent qu'elles
essaient d'en tuer un ou deux dans le
faux témoin jeter marquant la police non
au nom au le fourgon s'est fait
intercepter par une voiture de brigands
alliage et outils dans le vent vous
m'aimez payage trois divas et à la fin
j'ai jeté d'herlin renato j'aimerais
j'aimerais je mange pas être cachés bugs
je passe de sous pour récupérer le vélo
quelques jours de l'autre côté j'ai
bientôt un multi les gars c'est bon les
ishares va aller au carton cap d'agde au
oui j'ai même pas ajouté
jules type voici enfin la gamme voilà ça
reflète bien mon utilité dans cette game
je vais jouer ces métrages mécary si on
fait un job ci mettra chacun les gars je
vous rappelle que c'est la game qui va
me permettre de passer diamant c'est
celle que j'ai perdu avec dix autres
derrière d'affilée j'aimerais vraiment
que ça se reproduise ok on a une strate
alpha ici présent 20 ou quelqu'un qui va
se rebeller par mes tours il faut juste
que tu réussisses ton cul ouais ouais ça
face à face de l'autre côté elle sert à
rien d'autre a dit non c'est vrai ils
sont tous de l'autre côté
acheter son coin comme ça parce que je
suis choquée j'ai tué mon gars tu l'as
maya du tout cas on dirait que j'ai 8
ans et demi dans cette vidéo c'est
incroyable les gars je vous mets quoi je
vous mais calcule-t-il le thé pu le
boucler le tpiy et le tpir
auquel cas le bouclier c'est bien le
bouclier bouclier ou telle était le tp
le tpiy ok mais que les abords du
quartier
ok je me dépêche ok de l'état il sert en
vous servez le tpa mais oui je tpm et
grunge et là du coup je ferme la pierre
boillod du monde en jeu je vais prendre
in stone égard le moi c'est pas grave
les gars faut qu'on tienne trois minutes
minimum des impulsions de merde qui a
trompé le malin et ça dégage voilà
allègrement - mattel numéro un de
l'histoire témoin tu sors de ton
véhicule et u17 immédiatement sa recul
ça bat 4 as moi je fais moi j'aime mon
pays doit pied ouais j'suis insolent
attention miros élan qui l'attend pas et
passe en bas et le succès et la 100è
olalalala 7 à j'ai eu le temps de tuer
allemande en plus mon match et sont à
mettre en regard des matières solides
c'est oui et oui c'est ça qu'on veut
c'est le beau jeu est ce qu'on va mieux
faire
les gens se demandent dans la soirée on
va gagner
quel gâchis des rochelais rachid ammar
au fil du temps je gagne 500 personnes
s'en souvenir mais dégage de la place
c'est bon tu le sol j'ai balayé normal y
est les mariages ou des balayages
faisait balayage balayage en barque
échouée au poste les gars désolé ils
prendront pas les gars ça sent bien
moche c'est vrai j'ai peur [ __ ]
d'accord d'accord moi je prends tout
j'ai tout pris à l'égard courage vous
tenez vous tenez mika je te regarde
jouer avec ton copain il n'en était pas
passé et a gagné quatre points à l'ehpad
diamants non américaines pincemaille
tétons izina et bien les amis c'est sur
cette douce musique de noël que je vous
laisse vous êtes diamants d'un an grâce
à moi je vous appelle vous êtes content
oui très bon voilà c'est cadeau pour
vous les amis franchement la prochaine
fois quand je perds 3 game d'affilée je
vous appelle direct comme ça j'ai pas à
subir les onze défaites et la
frustration qui va avec
pour nous pas pour vous mais là oui je
m'appelle prouve pétrole oui eh bah
merci à vous les gars on et diamants on
a réussi je tenais à faire cette [ __ ]
de vidéos déjà parce qu'elle est sponso
avait choisi de surfer ou chez ensuite
moi je mets à base est barrée de faire
l'objectif diamant en vidéo je remercie
d'abord accepté de montjoie n'hésitez
pas à passer dans la chaîne youtube de
michael ou qui aura fait une chaîne
youtube et le switch d'alpha c'est ça
oui c'est un homme talentueux et les
nuls mais les talentueux alors je vais
vous laisser vous clash et puis je vais
dire au revoir aux joies mais c'est ça
vous a plu est attendu prochaine
ciao tout le monde
[Musique]